bajo la lluvia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
llantos y oraciones estos indígenas
tzotzil lo han perdido todo
mis cosas
por este extraño
los grupos armados se disputan 22
hectáreas de tierra en el municipio de
Santa Marta víctimas mortales y
desplazados que huyen de la violencia
tengo ganas de morir de miedo por eso
pensaba que ya iba a morir por por la
balacera
no es hasta que no pasan los sucesos que
el estado se moviliza y hace presencia
las dinámicas del narcotráfico se
extienden por el antes Pacífico Sureño
estado de Chiapas ahora convertida en
territorio de producción y ruta de paso
para el comercio de droga por el
corredor del Pacífico también en el sur
en el Estado de Guerrero en San Miguel
totolapan esta semana al menos 20
personas murieron en una guerra
territorial entre cárteles el alcalde
fue asesinado el número 94 desde el año
2000 el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador culpa al legado recibido
son organizaciones
que vienen de tiempo atrás
no surgieron En este gobierno
desde 2006 cuando el estado lanzó su
lucha contra los cárteles de la droga
más de 340.000 personas han muerto en
México